you don't strike me and i i don't mean
this to be offensive to you but you
don't strike me as a kind of guy that
would survive in a
plane crash type of scenario you are
correct
i don't think i would do well i was
thinking about that yesterday i'm fine
if i'm going down what am i doing am i
dapping up the homie next to me what am
i doing am i reaching a couple rows back
just to tell uh an elderly man like
thank you for your service i don't know
thank you for your support being old
he's putting up with millennials i just
got out of jail he's probably
what if he's a pedophile
tattoo uh yeah i don't think i would do
well i mean i don't think i'd do well in
a lot of tough scenarios you know really
but say you crash right you crash
what is some of your first moves when
you're on the ground these are these are
the things you got oh we'll make like
so you're saying not on impact i'm not
splat you crash okay but i am alive but
like i'm a little mangled
you're alive you're probably you're
doing a no how about this you're
pristine okay big word people were like
what oh i look good like fine
i mean literally like every movie action
hero i have like one star right here
yeah almost like better than when you
win i look like that dude in the the
insurance commercials what's his name oh
yeah yeah um
what's that guy's name
what first thing i'm doing
damn allstate guy oh uh yeah it's like
danger or something cool yeah danger
danger rick or something guys hot
first thing i would do what do you do
because this is it's important the first
thing you do is important yeah because
you're on an island you guys there's no
police coming over probably a couple
weeks
wow first thing i'm doing um
probably checking my phone
no
that's not being honest you could check
it
it's that's not that's done
the worst is going to be some idiot on
the beach the whole time like trying to
get their phone to work like hold it up
at the sun yeah shaking like asking the
stewardess can i get more coffee this
store just doesn't have an arm does
anybody yeah like anybody got boost
mobile nobody has nobody who's mobile in
general
realistically i think
i would probably try to get the youngest
people out of the plane of the crash
first but even that's weird you're on
the island yelling for babies
because they have the most potential in
life isn't because or you say seniors
and ladies first i think is it i think
so unless it's changed
maybe this is where the difference i
think ins just like
and
this is where things are changing is
like the cut off save the babies yeah
but you can't just be young where's the
kids at a little weird in 2022. where's
the kid the first thing you land you go
where's the kids at they're like all
right you should not if you just saluted
the guy behind you
that's the first thing you absolutely
say where's the kids at i don't know
what what are you who are you saying
first what's the first thing you're
doing
the first thing you got to do is be able
to provide food for everybody where oh
like on the island yeah trevor okay the
first thing you have to be able to do is
provide food for everybody because
people need to know if you're a leader
or not that's true because if you're not
a leader out of the gate then i think
you're you risk you take on a lot of
risk
uh i don't think you need to be like
insane alpha no you know you don't want
to fake it
you take the shirt off i'll probably
take your shirt off
or i'd rip this shirt off just to assert
dominance maybe just one sleeve or
something
no i think if you're gonna here's what
you don't want to happen you don't want
to try to rip your shirt off and you
can't get it off you can't do it i've
seen that happen at many frat parties it
always gets it always is caught on the
collar part because it's different
stitching up there well yeah and the
collar won't break yeah people were like
and then they just like pretend like
that was their plan the whole time yeah
like we know you're doing thorbin we
know what you're doing yeah went off
already yeah i mean i don't know i i
think um
so you gotta feed everybody so the first
thing you have to get is probably you're
going to get have to get some small
ground game so you're going to want to
do probably squirrel is easy to hunt
pheasant is one of the easiest things to
pheasant is oh pheasant's really easy if
you've just cut a crop or something
pheasants wall i know what a pheasant is
but also what is a pheasant
i've i've seen them little [ __ ] are
they um they're like not squirrels but
they're not chipmunks a pheasant is
about oh it's a bird so you're not it's
a small bird it's a small chicken i grew
up in california my whole life i don't
understand that i know pigeons and
seagulls oh dude oh these little guys oh
yeah these [ __ ] are legit baby
they're basically like a mexican they
almost look kind of mexican honestly
they all have a nice little like diamond
chain on them yeah i mean they look
you know like the mexican guy that comes
in with the
like the uh mariachi yes that's what
they they seem like they have that sort
of they look fast circumstance about it
are they not fast i feel like catching
that would be a little hard
uh pheasants one of the easiest things
to catch if you are if you're stuck
somewhere and you need to cook for
people i i already i can tell if you
you're going to be like more of a sous
chef you're going to be like the guys
coconuts because they can't move
yeah birds got legs and wings coconuts
none of those they're just chilling i
don't really have an option yeah so
coconuts is good unless he could get
some coconuts i think another thing you
could prepare for people if you want or
capture form squirrels
um
what else is something that's easy
rabbits is a little trickier than you
would think right if you could get
turtle that's an easy thing but you're
going to have to be able to get it open
here's the thing or you just use a
turtle shell to like chop a coconut bag
on you don't hurt the turtle but use its
back as like a cutting board yeah you
can't be the guy who's like let's don't
hurt the turtle in a plane crash you
gotta cause here's 20 22 man that's me
that's our millennials dude we're
[ __ ] we're like let's get the turtle
but let's not like i'll sacrifice a
coconut show but i'm using it for shoes
after
i need to use everything could you do it
though you think you could survive it no
i don't think damn i mean there's only
so many know when you're hard i'm asking
you seriously uh i i i mean i would give
it a a solid try
but you know i get mad if my coffee is
too hot at starbucks that's not the type
of guy who's going to make it in
wilderness right you know and you got to
be willing to sacrifice somebody
immediately the first thing you need to
do is take somebody else's life in order
to show that you are
dominant yeah i don't think so because i
remember one time i was really drunk in
college and i tried to fight a guy and i
went to go smash a glass bottle and the
glass bottle didn't break
so i don't think that i would that was
my you're like i'm just recycling yeah
right that was my t-shirt tear it didn't
break and after that you know i play the
back of my head a lot when i think about
alpha situations manly [ __ ] and i and i
just don't think you know i would give
it a good go but i would piggyback on
other people like i would become friends
with the guy who could catch a boar
right and then i'd be like bro i got the
cranberry sauce hey darren yeah exactly
i'm bringing like accents yeah you know
oh you need coconuts i got you bro let
me get a lamb chop for a coconut right
right let me trade let me do something
here right i mean i so yeah you would
definitely you would have more of a
skill set of a um i'll like shout people
out on instagram probably but i'll shout
you out for you know a couple years ago
i mean you could just let into a tree
like that when i was a when i was like
real young that was our instrument was
like writing you know i love you know
wrong you know that was an instagram
story you just like put a lock on a
fence with your initials and you're like
theo was here
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one